la préfecture du bas-rhin réplique elle
a saisi la justice concernant une
subvention publique de deux millions et
demi d'euros accordée à la future
mosquée de strasbourg
les échanges de courrier récent entre la
préfète du bas rhin et la maire de
strasbourg n'ont pas permis d'aboutir au
retrait de la délibération du conseil
municipal
la préfète josiane chevalier a décidé de
déférer la délibération litigieuse au
tribunal administratif de strasbourg
il s'agit d'obtenir l'annulation de la
délibération du conseil municipal dont
nous contestons la légalité
le budget de la mosquée eyyub sultan
anne qui deviendrait la plus grande
d'europe et de 25 millions d'euros
financés en majeure partie par des dons
de particuliers d'associations la future
mosquée de 16 mille cinq cents mètres
carrés suscite la polémique
son financement est jugée opaque par
certains avec des soupçons d' allégeance
envers la turquie d'erdogan
des accusations balayées par
l'association willy go russe en charge
du chantier
aucun état n'interfère dans les dix neuf
dans les décisions ou le fonctionnement
de la mosquée nous trouvons qu'il est
indécent et regrettable de nous renvoyer
à nos origines
nous ne sommes pas comptable de ce qu'il
se passe dans notre pays d'origine nous
ne sommes pas et ne serons jamais des
otages des agendas des uns et des autres
nous ne sommes pas dupes
l'astra de l'instrumentalisation qui est
faite des échéances à venir
nous avons voulu tenir cette conférence
de presse ici aujourd'hui pour dire très
clairement ça suffit la décision
d'attribuer une subvention de deux
millions et demi d'euros soit 10% du
total a provoqué la colère du ministre
de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin la mairie verte de
strasbourg finance une mosquée soutenu
par une fédération qui a refusé de
signer la charte des principes de
l'islam de france et qui défend un islam
politique
vivement que tout le monde ouvre les
yeux et que la loi séparatisme soit
bientôt votée et promulguée gène bars et
guéant n'a pas hésité à lui répondre
parce que du coup c'est une manière de
dire que le gouvernement souhaite
m en cause le concordat et les règles en
vigueur dans notre dans notre région
dans ce cas là je pense qu'il faut il
faut le dire clairement
et si par contre il a des doutes ou des
alertes par particulière concernant le
respect des valeurs de la république
c'est aussi à lui de le dire pour ma
part j'ai fait confiance et aux
responsables locaux antérieur et aux
services de l'état avec lesquels
j'entretiens un dialogue constant sur un
certain nombre de sujets
achevé en 2012 la grande mosquée de
strasbourg avait déjà bénéficié de fonds
publics comme le permet le régime
spécifique des cultes en alsace-moselle
partout ailleurs en france depuis 1905
les associations de culte ne peuvent
recevoir de subventions publiques
directes ou indirectes